hey ich habe vor ganz langer zeit schon
mal auf dem video reagiert wo leute auf
hohen gebäuden rom geklettert sind
alter schwede ist der irre und dieses
video habe ich mir vor einigen tagen
noch mal angeschaut und es hat
tatsächlich vier millionen aufrufe wow
so viele leute freuen sich wie ich hier
vor der kamera leider deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht freunde ihr seht hier schon
mal schaue ich mir noch mal ein video an
mich ich krieg hat schon kotzen alter
ich habe mir gedacht ich schauen wir
noch mal ein video an wo leute nicht
fremd oft heiß sind also besonders gary
compilation wo leute so über dächer
springen und klettern und alles das wo
ich lieber in die hölle gehen würde
ich würde allerdings sagen wir fangen
direkt an ich denke mal direkt auf
beachtung scheiße
was
das sind locker zehn meter ich versuche
jetzt nicht mehr so viel zu pausieren
weil alter das ist also das ist wirklich
unfassbar
es ist bei mir immer so wenn ich sachen
eklat finde gehe ich einfach weg
ne
ich kriege nicht mal ich habe wahnsinnig
ist sich sogar letztens auch so ein
chinesischer freeclimber gestorben dabei
ich hab mal ein bisschen recherchiert
und ja vor einiger zeit ist so wie ich
bin außer atem ich gucke mir das einfach
nur an und schwitze es ist vor einiger
zeit wirklich ein asiatischer
freeclimbing parkour läufer über
hochhäuser keine ahnung was gestorben
weil er den halt verloren hat also leute
nehmt euch keinen beispiel an solche
personen legt euch stattdessen einfach
aufs sofa und frisst ships sind wir
gucken allerdings direkt mal weiter acom
janina hand der kommt nimmt die andere
hand auch noch rechne man dann bis nur
noch an den schuhen alter das ist doch
nicht sein ernst okay geht wieder
hochachtung
das finde ich sogar noch viel schlimmer
wenn leute wirklich so runter filmen
jetzt kommen bestimmt auch einige leute
an die mich schon seit langer zeit
kennen und argumentieren er lukas doch
das bild hier mal auf instagram
hochgeladen
ich heiße erstmal laser luca könnte mir
gern folgen das bild ist allerdings
fällt also da saß ich nicht auf einem
hochhaus in manhattan sondern auf einem
bett
hab das ausgeschnitten und dann
ja aber das hier ist tatsächlich echt ey
ich krieg die gucken wenn ich sowas sehe
kommt nein was machst du nimmst du an
gott
auch weiter ach du scheiße kommen wir
noch rein ja mach noch ein ja noch ein
kommt
unfassbar
was macht der hier
okay dass er sogar noch krasser
ach du scheiße ich will da halleluja
das gesehen
denn je
warum rega ich komme da nicht drauf klar
er springt er auch noch rum machten
salto auf so was ich hätte nicht gedacht
dass es noch schlimmer wird als die
ersten szenen aber bei der ersten szene
war es ja wirklich so das war locker
meter auf dem der da die sachen gemacht
hat aber das hier wirklich thema weiter
auf play rückwärts du weißt du links ist
ein weg und was denkt er sich ja er
läuft da einfach drüber über die perser
auf alter
mein abrutsch mit einem kack drexler und
du fällst direkt in den tod ich glaube
das ist somit einer der schlimmsten tode
die es gibt wenn du nämlich schon sie
ist ok fall gerade runter und du weißt
zack in zwei sekunden alles vorbei also
sowas finde ich wirklich am
allerschlimmsten leuten eine go pro auf
den kopf haben was ihn noch mal das
ganze song bisschen weitet von der
ansicht alter
die kommen ja immer auf neue ideen
da findet ein kumpel ob jacob
ja wenn etwas so erhält mich fest und
dann irgendwann sind wir fallen beide
unternehmen sind beide tot
also das ist das ist wirklich komplett
wahnsinn
ach du scheiße das ist wirklich da habe
ich nach habe ich wirklich kein
verständnis mehr für
ich will gar nicht mehr sehen
einige leute haben unter meine erste
reaktion auf sonne freight of
compilation das ja auch krank da kann
man sich einfach mal das glück bei
brechen einige leute haben auf jeden
fall kommentierte luca direction ist
voll geprägt
egal ich denke steht zu dritt auf
sommertour
hätte doch komplett bescheuert einige
leute hat mir vorgeworfen meine reaktion
sei übertrieben und und gepflegt aber
leute also wirklich ich zeige euch das
macht ich weiß nicht ob man das ihr die
also dass gerade schon direkt aber wenn
ich mal in der hand hier wird darauf
liegen habe typisch wenn ich lag da habe
ich meine hand hier liegen
und dann nämlich die hoch altergruppe
wie ich wieder wie das die spitze
alle leute
die auch höhenangst haben die wissen was
ich meine wenn sie sich solche videos
anschauen viacom wedel da mit deinem
safestick rum alter beugt sich da noch
so drüber ich denke einfach nur da muss
einfach einmal okay dass das ist nicht
aufheitern das war einfach nur
lebensmüde warum hängt man sich hinten
an einen zug dran bei ihm jetzt halt die
sache hier drunter ist noch so eine
ablage dh da kann jetzt jetzt ist keine
ablage mehr darunter gott den kennen wir
schon
der war der war auch in meiner letzten
action tatsächlich drin das ist nämlich
so ein typ der macht das wirklich gegen
wie beruflich oder so ich weiß es
bescheuert beruflich aber was machst du
so ja ich bin lebens mühe macht da
wirklich sehr viele youtube videos zu
wir darum klettert und also ich verstehe
es einfach nicht auch so was
ist ja nicht schon schlimm genug dass er
hausfriedensbruch betreibt und da oben
rum zittert wenn er nur ansatzweise so
schwitzige hände hätte wie ich hier an
mein name aus sieht man das video am
glänzen ist dann wird er direkt
abrutschen
ich habe da überhaupt kein verständnis
film es geht auch glaube ich hierbei gar
nicht mehr so krass darum dass manfred
veits ist also eine gewisse formen der
höhenangst hat sondern es geht einfach
darum dass man auf
neu
okay das ist hoch
der der thomas im nebel also was ich
gerade sagen wollte ich glaube es geht
hierbei gar nicht mehr so krass um bei
meinem schwitzen und sondern einfach um
die angst zu sterben
das ist keine frage ob heitz compilation
sondern eine frau doch vollendet
compilation eigentlich eher ich meine
hier muss man ganz ehrlich sagen hat er
zumindest noch etwas zum festhalten und
es ist okay da kommt wieder solche leute
nur
oder hier nur also den hat man ja gerade
schon aber nur die beiden hände
ich hatte einmal so eine situation wo
ich am hochhaus saß und darunter gehen
wollte die fassade was auch für mich
sondern challenge war die ich selber
eigentlich machen wollte weil ich da
meine angst quasi ins auge geblickt habe
ich weiß nicht heißt dass schocktherapie
ich weiß es nicht aber dass ich auf
jeden fall facing nur vier mäßig
darunter laufen wollte also dass sie
jetzt noch mal das foto und da das habe
ich nicht gemacht
ich hatte ich war in dieser position
dass sich 45 grad erstand weiter kam ich
nicht meine meine beine haben aufgehört
zu arbeiten ich
ich glaube jeder der höhenangst hat der
weiß was ich meine und ich habe
eigentlich meine höhenangst auch relativ
gut im griff würde ich sagen hat sich
war letztens in new york bis vor ein
paar tagen und habe dort das rockefeller
center besichtigt also ich war oben auf
einem 400 meter hochhaus drauf aber
wirklich wenn ich sowas sehe ich finde
das hat nichts mehr mit höhenangst zu
tun natürlich klar ich schwitze hier
wieder des todes aber dass auch wieder
der hier ne der typische typ da wieder
der typische typ sehr gute aussage luca
das ist einfach nur noch lebensmittel
also wirklich diese menschen die hier
gezeigt werden das hat mir glaube ich
auch schon mal es ist wieder der gleiche
typ die menschen sind einfach lebensmüde
das hat das hat nichts nichts mit
höhenangst zu tun oder so
ich habe ich habe da wirklich keine
worte für wenn ich das so sehen also ich
bin ganz ehrlich ich kann mir das nicht
geben also ich stehe hier wirklich mit
verschränkten armen ich nehme an
gewissen form geratenen schutzhaltung
ein obwohl mir gerade nichts passiert
ich meine natürlich da ich lege auch im
dritten vierten stock hier aber halt
auch mit meinen beiden füßen auf dem
boden der nicht wackelt und das hat man
halt auch oft bei hohen gebäuden dass es
irgendwie um wackelt ich mein ich bin
froh dass er jetzt gerade zumindest
wieder hochklettern in den anderen
videos hat man es nicht gesehen wie
leute da irgendwie ihre hohe position
verlassen haben
ach du scheiße ich dachte klettert hoch
bist du ich dachte gerade
hey
hast du dich gut rum geschwungen
kälter das
wieder hoch du brauchst nur einmal in
kraft in einem fuß und du fährst runter
teilt sie wahrscheinlich noch offenen
auto drauf oder autofahrer auch noch
steht alter das ist einfach lebensmüde
und so was ist also wirklich sowas
sollte nicht auf youtube sein
anders stellte mich dass häufig videos
allerdings auch band meine damen und
herren ich kann da wirklich nicht
hingucken wenn ich so was sehen
ich weiß nicht also vielleicht sind
unter euch auch einige leute die auch
von kranken respekt vor verhüllen haben
aber für mich ist das einfach wirklich
das ist einfach nur noch eine lebensmüde
compilation es tut mir leid dass ich in
diesem video sehr sehr oft gesagt habe
das ist lebensmüde seid ihr bescheuert
wahnsinnig keine ahnung was aber das ist
meine ehrliche meinung so leute nehmt
euch ein beispiel an solchen leuten die
machen alles für ein bild oder für ein
video irgendwo es also wirklich
irgendwann mal ende reactions auf trade
off heiz oder scared compilation videos
das ist das einzige wo ich wirklich vor
meinem pc stehe und eigentlich normalen
video aufnehmen wo ich wirklich
gänsehaut habe und schwitze wenn es euch
gefallen hat das gern like darf wenn ich
es nochmal machen soll
schreibt mir gerne in die kommentare
werde ich aber den nächsten wochen
monaten es erstmal nicht machen
[Musik]